60 years ago this october
westside story was released it would go
on to win
10 competitive oscars
most famously for
best supporting actress
among its other smaller awards was best
picture of the year
and that is what i am here to present
the father david parfit jean-louis levi
and philippe carcasson producers
judas and the black messiah chaka king
charles d
king and ryan coogler producers mank
cion chaffin eric roth and douglas
urbanski
producers minari christina o
producer nomad land francis mcdormand
peter spears molly asher dan
janvi and chloe zhao producers
promising young woman ben browning
ashley fox emerald fennell
and josie mcnamara producers sound of
metal
baird hammerling and sasha ben arosh
producers
the trial of the chicago seven mark
platt and stuart besser producers
and the oscar goes to
nomad land
[Music]
[Music]
on behalf of my fellow producers peter
spears
molly asher d'angelo and the one and
only francis mcdormand
we thank the academy and we thank our
brilliant fellow nominees
and we thank all the hearts and hands
that come together to make this movie
from searchlight pictures jessica budder
who trusted us with her beautiful book
to our brilliant cinematographer joshua
james richards
and to the entire normal and company
we want to show our deepest gratitude to
linda mae
swanky bob wells and nomadic community
all the people we met on the road thank
you for teaching us the power of
resilience and hope
and for reminding us what true kindness
looks like
and now i give you fur
no i'm not i'm fran
please watch our movie on the largest
screen
possible and one day very very soon
take everyone you know into a theater
shoulder to shoulder in that dark space
and watch every film that's represented
here tonight
we give this one to our wolf
you